the british government has released a
raft of policies today all aimed at
hitting ambitious carbon reduction
targets and demonstrating leadership
ahead of the crucial u.n climate summit
cop 26. so what's been announced well
the focus is on those sectors most
responsible for emissions that means
decarbonizing the way we heat our homes
so there's a 450 million pound fund to
help people switch from gas boilers to
low carbon alternatives like electric
heat pumps transport is also a big
emitter so the government will invest
620 million pounds in grants for
electric vehicles and street charging
points alongside other investments in
hydrogen and aviation fuel technologies
and of course all this electricity we're
going to be using has to be clean or
there's no point so the uk has now
committed to delivering exactly this by
2035 that means more wind and solar
power and an attempt to approve at least
one more large-scale nuclear power plant
in the coming years
the government says that its net zero
strategy will support 440 000 jobs by
2030 and that tens of billions of pounds
in private and public money has been
mobilized to pay for this green
industrial revolution although the
treasury has said that additional taxes
may be needed if there's a shortfall so
what next well all of these
announcements have been timed to help
boost the uk's position as a climate
leader ahead of the cop 26 meeting in
glasgow which is now just days away the
prime minister says that the uk strategy
sets an example to other nations to
raise their own net zero ambitions
but i've talked to senior members of the
chinese government who say that won't be
the case
china is the world's largest polluter
and has already committed to peak carbon
emissions before 2030 and net zero by
2060.
we do not need the actions taken by the
uk to encourage us
china also set up a very clear roadmap
together with a clear time frame
policies measures and actual feasible
actions to support its double
targets
we need
to have the biggest drop
biggest cut on the carbon intensity
compared with all the other countries
this is the best possible efforts we can
make given the current development stage
and the capacity of china
we simply hope all the developed
countries can do the same by honoring uh
their words with actual actions
the stage is now set for a difficult
climate summit if china continues to be
unwilling to make further concessions on
carbon reduction or on the domestic
phase-out of coal